so a few weeks ago we were lucky enough
to see some leaked concept art photos of
an Iron Man suit this is different than
what we saw for the leaked photos of the
mark 85 which is the golden red armor
there have been many theories in regards
to what this armor could potentially be
some popular one state that this is
actually not a fully formed armor
meaning that the nanobots haven't
actually fully turned into the armor
this is sort of an in-between which kind
of makes sense seeing as it's silver and
has sort of a muscular appearance of
Tony Stark's arms and another one is
that he actually doesn't have enough
nanobots left after the battle with fan
oohs on Titan and nebula has to actually
give him some parts so he can get a full
Ironman suit to get away from Titan but
I think that there's two major
possibilities of what it could be that
no one's explored yet also my giveaway
still continues I'm giving away copies
of Avengers infinity war and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero I'll be picking another winner
this weekend okay so my first thought
looking at this is it's vibranium when I
see this it reminds me of Bucky's arm
that King tajalli gave him and if I sit
here and think about it it actually
makes sense
we know that Tony goes to Wakanda we
know this from an interview that Robert
Downey jr. did in which you can clearly
tell that the background is Wakanda and
he's got his blond hair and gray facial
hair so it leads us to believe that he
is in the future
so we know he goes to Wakanda and once
he's there you best believe that he's
gonna want to know a little bit more
about vibranium vibranium actually does
something that his nanotech soup doesn't
do and that is absorb energy and then
release it as an attack anyway
genius told me to strike it you didn't
say how hot we see this in black panther
and we see this in infinity war whenever
T'Challa is fighting in that purple
burst of energy comes out that's him
releasing the energy that he's absorbed
we know that Tony's going to face Thanos
again with the Infinity stones and what
are the Infinity stones except just pure
raw power it would be nice to have armor
that could absorb some of that power
from some of the stones and then be able
to release it back at danos so a
vibranium suit could make a lot of sense
and be very impactful against Thanos but
another thing that I think this armor
could be is that I think it could be
dipped in yo metal guru metal is the
same thing that Thor's hammer Mjolnir is
made out of and the same thing that
storm breakers made out of as well in
the feared self comic series Tony Stark
actually goes to Odin and he asked him
if he could use the dwarfs and Ned oval
ear to help him forge some new weapons
Odin grants him access and what Tony
does instead of just throwing his armor
in there he jumps into the VAT of molten
guru himself with the armor on now I'm
not saying that we're going to get this
exact scene in a movie obviously Odin's
not even in the picture anymore but we
do know from the end of infinity war
that Stormbreaker was able to overpower
all the Infinity stones combined Thor
will most likely share this information
with the rest of the Avengers and Tony
beam Tony will probably want some of
that uber metal for himself not to
mention that uber metal has the ability
to absorb magic and energy as well in
the comics this was called the iron
destroyer armor because it was made the
same way that Odin's destroyer was made
and Tony Stark jumps in with his
bleeding-edge nanotech armor as well so
it's still millions and millions of
nanobots that he doesn't have to wear
all the time but can form on his command
much like we saw an infinity war so
there is a president's for this story
arc to take place in the movie it's
definitely Tony Stark's strongest armor
imagine Stormbreaker but an Iron Man
armor that's what it is and that's what
I think we could possibly be looking at
here in these concept
art photos but let me know what you all
think do you think that this could be
vibranium armor or earu metal armor let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below don't forget to subscribe comment
and like for your chance to win the
giveaway and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]